joint exercises between the U.S and
Philippine militaries are just wrapping
up out here in the Pacific and while
these exercises happen every year this
year marked the biggest show of force
ever
right now we're watching a drone fly
laps off the coast of this beach and
behind me is an Avenger platform loaded
with stinger missiles that are going to
take down that drone
our task is to be ready with defensive
weapon systems like this certainly this
is a great opportunity to do that for
U.S soldiers and our leaders we wouldn't
be here unless it was at the request of
our partners through the Philippines and
it demonstrates not only a real
capability should it be required but
hopefully it demonstrates to our
partners a special relationship as one
of our five treaty alliances that we
have out here
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
what's up
[Music]
these exercises are coming on the heels
of a major new agreement that's giving
the U.S greater access to Philippine
bases
[Music]
U.S being the biggest or one of the
biggest players in the west Philippine
Sea these efforts are especially
important as a People's Republic of
China continues to advance its
illegitimate claims in the west
Philippines Sea
[Music]
I'm confident that regardless of the
threat my responsibility is to train our
soldiers to be prepared we demonstrated
some of that capability out here during
the sly fire
our opportunity and our responsibility
and our mission is to defeat a range of
threats if those are presented
following these exercises the president
at house to meet with President Biden to
talk about their commitment to defense
and other ways the countries can work
together like potential economic
cooperation
foreign
[Music]